aquí tenemos cuatro números y lo que me
gustaría que hicieran es sacar un lápiz
y papel para usar este vídeo y ver si
pueden ordenar estos números de menor a
mayor el menor debe ir a la izquierda y
luego el siguiente mayor y así hasta
llegar al mayor de todos así que pausa
el vídeo y trata de hacerlo muy bien
ahora vamos a hacer esto juntos y la
forma en que me gusta hacerlo es
comenzar en el valor posicional más
grande y comparar los números y luego
continuar moviéndonos hacia la derecha a
valores posicional es cada vez más
pequeños así que podemos empezar en la
posición de las unidades este número
tiene cero unidades este número tiene
cero unidades este número tiene cero
unidades y este otro tiene cero unidades
de modo que la posición de las unidades
no nos ayuda mucho pero luego podemos
pasar a la posición de las décimas este
número tiene siete décimas este número
tiene cero décimas por lo que sabemos
que el segundo número es menor que el
primero éste tiene siete décimas éste
pero décimas no importa lo que haya en
las siguientes posiciones a la derecha
este número que tenemos aquí también
tiene siete décimas al igual que el
primer número y este último número
también tiene siete décimas de modo que
sabemos que al comparar las unidades y
luego la posición de las décimas este
número que tenemos justo aquí es el más
pequeño de los cuatro números todos
tienen ser unidades pero éste también
tiene cero décimas así que lo voy a
poner de este lado 0.0 74 ahora vamos a
la posición de las centésimas este
número tiene cero centésimas ya hemos
usado este número este número tiene
siete centésimas y luego este número
puede que no sea obvio pero la posición
de las centésimas se puede ver como cero
podemos poner un cero en la posición de
las centésimas y no cambiar el valor así
que éste también tiene cero centésimas
de modo que estos tres números tienen
las mismas unidades las mismas décimas
pero este número 0.77
tiene siete centésimas mientras que los
otros dos tienen cero centésimas así que
este va a ser el más grande de nuestros
cuatro números este es más grande que
estos otros dos debido a lo que vemos en
la posición de las centésimas no importa
lo que haya en la posición de las
milésimas o más allá así que ponemos el
0.77 justo aquí ya hemos usado este
número y ahora nuestra tarea es comparar
estos dos números que son iguales en la
posición de las unidades las décimas y
las centésimas por lo que tenemos que ir
a la posición de las milésimas este
número tiene siete milésimas y este
número tiene cero milésimas de modo que
este número es más pequeño que este que
tenemos aquí lo escribiré a continuación
0.7 y luego el tercero más pequeño o el
siguiente número más grande es el que
tenemos aquí cero punto 707 y hemos
terminado la idea principal es comparar
los valores posicional es más
significativos primero los valores
posicional es más grandes
y luego con base en eso seguir
moviéndonos hacia la derecha para
comparar los valores posicional es menos
y menos significativos